عمليه البريه والشيكه حسن
توفيق النقتا مهمتان في كلام اردوغان
الاولى ان العمليه العسكريه البريه
والشيكه ووشيكا جدا والامر الان هو عباره
عن تمهيد جوي ومدفعي للسماح للقوات البريه
بالتبغل في مرحله مقبله النقطه الثانيه
اردوغان لم يتحدث اليوم عن عمق يصل الى 30
كيلو مترا هي المنطقه الامنه التي عاده ما
يتحدث عنها الرئيس التركي اليوم هو قال
اننا سنذهب الى حيث يتطلب الامر لحمايه
امننا القومي وايضا تحدث عن الدعم
الامريكي لقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه تحدث عن
هذه العمليه امام حشد من انصاره خلال
افتتاح مشروع في في احدى المدن التركيه
وهو بذلك يريد القول ان تركيا ذاهبه
لتنفيذ العمليه البريه التي لطالما هددت
بتنفيذها في مناطق رئيسيه محدده كوباني تل
رفعت منبج هذه المناطق هي
الاهداف الاهم بالنسبه لتركيا للسيطره على
الشريط الحدودي مع سوريا من خلال فصائل
المعارضه التي ستشارك بطبيعه الحال في
العمليات البريه خلال فتره وجيزه وقد تلقت
التعليمات منذ فتره ليست قصيره للاستعداد
لشن هذه العمليه على مناطق
وقواعد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ولكن
العمليه البريه تتاخر قليلا لان تركيا لا
تريد ان تتكبد خسائر في هذه المنطقه
باعتبار انها الحصن الاخير للقوات الكرديه
وبالتالي ستكون المواجهه مواجهه شرسه
للغايه شكرا لك يا حسين اسد من اسطنبول